dans le mur alors est ce que tu veux
jouer ou non non je vais bien je vais
jouer non m'excite moi j'étais un
mauvais client cgt n'est pas du tout ce
sont 110 vies c'est pareil ça tape alors
est ce que jean louis murat vous est
pris pour une interview jugement dernier
jean louis murat
c'est le jugement vers liège mais mais
j'aurais eu ras vous pensé à la mort une
demi-heure par jour
ah bon donc vous êtes prêts pour
l'interview jugement dernier
jean louis murat quand tu étais petit as
tu essayé de regarder sous le bureau la
maîtresse jamais il était plein as-tu
enfermer des élèves le sexe féminin dans
les cabinets jamais il est en plein air
jean louis durand tu jouer au docteur
avec des copains jamie n'est jamais
malade
très bien merci jean louis murat avec ce
professeur d'anglais qui t'a fait lire
coridon es tu sûr qu'il ne sais vraiment
rien passé sexuellement tunisiens bien
sûr piment jean louis murat
as-tu utiliser ta notoriété pour obtenir
les avantages particuliers des fois des
bonnes places dans les stocks comme ça
absorbe tu as encore des substances
illicites
jamais jamais dit mais tu as choupin
justement c'est bien pour ça que ton ton
purgatoire un éventuel m'est étranger
c'est il arrivait d'avoir envie de la
femme d'un autre jamais gêné principe
est il arrivé de trompeta femmes
jamais gêné principe est il arrivé de
trompeta maîtresse
c'est jamais une maîtresse jean louis
murat
as tu ne serait ce qu'une fois emmerder
le monde par plaisir jamais
je pense que même dieu tu vas arriver à
le faire chier au jugement dernier
j'espère faire des photos pour reporter
sans frontières alors cet appareil photo
tu fais des photos ouais tu les fais pas
développé et au mois de juin s'est vendu
aux enchères au profit de reporter sans
frontières s'appelle photos de stars
prend le dunk à des stars c'est une
bonne idée et affûté vu c'était mieux
passer parce qu'avais linda hardy toulet
minardi sur l rosissait ici ainsi les
deux petits sans emploi qu'elle arrêtait
veulent montrer ce soir